I need to turn in New York City where
crime is on the rise attacks on police
officers are becoming more and more
prevalent and a string of anti-semitic
attacks leaves the Jewish community on
edge
this weekend five were stabbed during a
Hanukkah celebration at a rabbis home in
New York State New York City mayor de
Blasio spoke out to give his condolences
but he also placed the blame squarely on
President Trump an atmosphere of hate
has been developing in this country over
the last few years a lot of it is
emanating from Washington and it's
having an effect on all the wait so
you're saying you're blaming the
president but from Washington I'm saying
but we have to be clear we need a
different tone starting in Washington
yeah
joining me now is Joe Borelli he's the
New York City Council Minority Whip
thank you so much councilman for joining
us here tonight what's your reaction
when you hear the mayor that you work
with there you realize you're in the
other party you're in the minority but
what he put your action when the mayor
says look Jason I'm not surprised this
isn't even the first time mayor de
Blasio has proven how buried his head is
in the sand on anti-semitism here in New
York City six months ago there was
another spike in anti-semitic crimes in
Brooklyn and he declared to the media
that anti-semitism is a right wing
movement I don't think I have to explain
to your viewers that central Brooklyn
isn't exactly a hotbed of Republican
activity and these weren't Magga hat
people doing the crimes yet he
deliberately misled people about the
cause of anti-semitism just like he's
deliberately misleading people about the
causes today now the priorities of this
mayor what New York City are doing walk
us through I mean you have things like
bail reform and releasing prisoners and
giving out gift cards I mean things that
are just foreign to the rest of us that
live in the real world it really makes
us question our priorities we have this
bail reform which advocates tell us that
it's just you know about marijuana and
low-level crimes but this weekend we saw
a violent attack on a police officer on
camera for everyone to see it should
have been locking him lock him up and
throw away the key and yet this perp was
actually released back onto the street
before that cop was even off his tour
that perp was bad
on that corner before this cop was home
on the couch with his family this would
be the priority of the Democratic Party
I mean this is video we're looking at it
this person goes to the jail and is back
out before this guy shift is even done
and this bail Reform is going into full
effect in just 26 hours and New Yorkers
should be concerned we're talking about
hate crimes this weekend also a woman
was released from custody
after assaulting three Jewish women only
to be released in the next day assault
more Jewish women this is the state of
play in New York City and this should be
a warning to all the viewers around the
country that this is the type of
government they'll get if you elect
progressive Democrats beat be be
forewarned frankly I'm telling this city
New York City I travel there pretty
regularly with Fox that city has totally
changed from the time where it was weird
Rudy Giuliani and and Charlie and mr.
Carrick kulish commissioner Carrick to
what Bill de Blasio was doing there and
there are people fleeing at every moment
I mean the numbers of people flowing out
of New York going to places like Florida
South Carolina and other beautiful
places it's unbelievable what's
happening in the state of New York it is
there was a report out today we won the
prize we lost 180,000 residents to other
states where the best state I guess for
that this year we're also the best state
for that this decade but it's palpable
you know mayor de Blasio is a failed
mayor and you don't have to take my word
for it when he ran for president not one
American in 100 answered a poll saying
the job he's doing we want that for our
country I mean so you know he should
take that as a grain of salt but perhaps
recalibrate readjust the things he does
and and hopefully recalibrate the city
in the right direction
ya know it's it's unbelievable what
you're going through there are a lot of
good people there in New York City but
the priorities tell me very specifically
what should be done to protect the
Jewish community because there been is
just this huge rash during Hanukkah of
attacks look my colleagues Jewish
Democrats by the way very brave ones
have been asking for more police more
security cameras more security guards
India Shiva's and in in in houses of
worship all across the city for months
again this rise is not new we have a
a recent rise in December but this has
been a year long thing I think 64
percent rise in anti-semitic hate crimes
and finally now after all this time now
we're going to implement more police
officers the mayor also had a hate crime
task force formed in September and he
basically hired half the positions
because it wasn't a priority it's just
not a priority Jason and that has to
change no it does have to change Joe
Morelli I appreciate your leadership on
this issue and coming on to explain it
to the rest of us who really do
appreciate it and have a wonderful happy
and safe new year particularly in New
York City we people should still come to
Times Square Jason is still a safe city
they should still come yeah the way that
New York City Police Department locks
down that that downtown right there by
the ball I'm telling you it's amazing
let them bless them thank you no it
should be a good night tomorrow night